i gave away two million dollars
personally uh donated to uh after-school
all-stars in the form of cash and uh and
actual physical products we gave 250 000
bands uh like workout bands uh like
digital ones you know what i mean like
fit fit fitbits
250 000 kind of fitbits to uh to kids in
underprivileged city so we could
encourage them to get fit and healthy
and we donated 1.2 million to to fund
the staffing
and i can truthfully tell you that when
i did that i did it because i wanted to
feel better and i can tell you now that
it didn't actually make me feel that
much better i share that because i don't
know how many people would say that
um and i just want to keep this keep
this channel 100 real i think a lot of
times at least for me like i want to do
things because i want to find meaning
and um i had a really really interesting
conversation and so the other day i had
a four-hour conversation uh with what
i'll say a friend of mine but i consider
him a friend hopefully he considers me a
friend dr john berardi and he sold his
company of the majority stake in his
company for over nine figures and he
doesn't do anything right now actively
i've had two unbelievable conversations
with john and i'm always very grateful
for my time with him there were two
statements that he made through that
four hours that have stuck with me um
since then and one from the former
conversation that i had with him that
really kind of changed my my life and my
outlook
and from the first conversation what he
talked about was how
he said you need to look at things
and consume content for people who are
outside of the matrix and i was like
what do you mean by that he was like
everyone's inside of the matrix everyone
is trying to make money right everyone's
trying to make money they're operating
from a place of scarcity they're
operating from a place of desire of
wanting something more than what they
currently have and whenever they're
doing that they're like they're
operating from a different energy level
and i don't think he used that exact
word but that's that's kind of how i
perceived it and that was like my big
takeaway from the first one and i think
that between my first conversation my
second was about six or nine months i'm
feeling this kind of shift that's
happening within us you know laila and i
as we as we start this channel and you
know we write the book which you guys if
you haven't heard of it's 100 million
offers uh it's got a lot of good reviews
it's 99 cents i made it 99 cents because
i want everyone to be able to afford it
that's as cheap as jeffy b will let me
do it
um and so yeah i'm still true to the to
the cause of having nothing to sell you
all right um and anyway so i had this
conversation with john
and the first question i asked him
when i shifted the conversation to kind
of personal stuff i said
now that you you know you've made what
you have you made your exit i was like
you know
how how do you create and destroy
meaning he was like huh that's an
interesting question and i was like like
in work like how do you create and
destroy meaning in the things that you
work on
and he paused and he looked at me and i
felt like he was staring into my soul
and he was like why do you think work
needs to be meaningful
i was like
ah okay and this is why i love talking
to people who
who are who are outside of the matrix
right there's so much perspective and
later in the conversation i was like
well then outside of work you know like
how do you gain meaning and he's like
why do you think work why do you think
life needs to be meaningful
and he's like just hold for a second
so
if you say that life has to be
meaningful then what happens is you
create this desire right that life must
be a certain way which means we're not
accepting life as it currently is and as
soon as we say that life has to be a
certain way it must be meaningful then
we create this deficit this deficiency
between where we are and where we want
to be and so in so doing we create the
deficiency that we're trying to avoid by
saying it must be a certain way and i
was like ah
god and so it just made me realize a lot
of the
you know i in the in the in the book i
think my first book jim long secrets
which is a gym book for transparency
this book is for all businesses
uh but my first book was a gym book and
i think the opening passage uh says is
from orson scott card we question all of
our beliefs except for those that we
truly believe and those who never think
to question at all
and i always take that to heart because
the beliefs that we truly hold dear are
the ones that we don't eat they operate
in the background of our minds their
assumptions that we make
on how the world is and how it's
supposed to be how it must be how it
should be right what we have to do right
i'm like i must create meaning i should
work should be meaningful but by
creating that
i end up creating an equation of
deficiency which then ends up
making or forcing myself to not
experience that right and so i'll tell
you a quick story so when i was in
college i dated a girl who was really
really obsessed with happiness and she
might be completely over this chapter in
her life i'm sure she is but at the time
she was really into happiness and
positive psychology she even majored in
psychology so everything was always like
does this make me happy does this make
me happy does this make me happy right
so it's like we're studying for a thing
he's like does this make me happy
and so for me i ended up actually
getting really sick of that concept
because i felt like i was always
analyzing and being like no like this
doesn't make me happy right i got so
frustrated with it i got so in my head
about like happiness happiness happiness
that i remember that i gave myself the
mantra
[ __ ] happiness and so as soon as i said
this is how i'm going to live i was like
[ __ ] happiness i'm just going to get
[ __ ] done and i'm going to move forward
i feel like i ended up actually
experiencing more joy in the work that i
was doing i didn't realize this but as
as we kind of reached another quote
mountaintop or whatever you want to call
it as we've kind of succeeded in
business and whatnot we i created
another happiness
uh placeholder right which i now called
meaning or fulfillment right by doing
that i created yet another equation of
deficiency in my own life which is
always analyzing my work and saying is
this meaningful do i get fulfillment
from this and all of that kind of jazz
but for me what ends up happening is
like if i go donate all this money and i
feel nothing i feel like i failed right
and
and then the question is like when you
donate are you do should you feel better
i assumed that i was supposed to feel
better right feel good but i didn't this
has been kind of the the thing that i am
doing right now or at least this is what
i'm thinking through so i'm sharing this
with the channel
it has been
i used the word it's been meaningful for
me to
give myself
the
excuse or give myself permission rather
to not find meaning in things and that
has been
unbelievably freeing
which is just giving myself permission
to work on things that
i may or may not find meaningful
but to simply do the thing
and i i think that for me
giving myself permission to not find
meaning has allowed me to accept reality
as it currently is and by accepting it
as it currently ends is i have i do not
have a deficiency that i must resolve
between where i am and where i think it
should be
and by doing that i have um
i've you know i've just i've enjoyed the
process more so i'll put it that way i
have less uh less anxiety around those
things not to see that anxiety is bad it
is a human condition or part of the
human condition um but it has been
something that i have experienced by by
first saying [ __ ] happiness earlier in
my life and then creating meaning as the
new happiness thing that i should be
striving for and again i think now it's
removing meaning or destroying the idea
that something should be meaningful
should not be meaningful that has been
very very valuable for me simply
focusing on the work at hand and doing
it well according to my values
which is whether this is meaningful or
not the way that i choose to live is
according to these values and is the way
that i am completing this work is the
way that i am showing up on this meeting
is the way that i am conducting myself
is the way that i am making this
decision in alignment with those values
and in thinking like that i feel like i
am able to do it in the present rather
than in the future i'm able to walk
with the values that i choose
rather than
try and pursue
meaning
in and of itself which created a
deficit between where i was and where i
wanted to go
which created a negative experience
again not that negative experience are
bad but i have a preference of not
having them if i can avoid them i show
you this i know this is a little bit
more heady than more more of my my
natural stuff talking about money but um
i guess i make this because i know a lot
of entrepreneurs are like me hopefully
maybe not not hopefully like me but
hopefully they're just like themselves
but if you were like me in that you
strive for these things i can tell you
that
i got no more meaning
from
giving lots of money away um
at all taking the actions that i am
taking
with the intention of being aligning
being in alignment with the values that
i find meaningful
has been the thing
that has been truly freeing for me
mentally
and i make this channel because it feels
in alignment with my values i wrote the
book
and the books because they're in
alignment with my values you know
building acquisition.com and and taking
interest in the companies that we do in
our portfolio has been in alignment with
the values rather than saying is this
company meaningful
is my work with this company meaningful
because here's the one that really gets
me tricked up and this is also something
that john brought up which is like
admitting that and again this may be
contrary to a lot of people's religious
beliefs i don't mean to offend anyone
that is not my intention here but my
belief my viewpoint of the world is that
when we die nothing happens and when you
and legacy is a myth and so when
the idea of taking money and then having
my kids
right then have something i think that
ruins people i think wealth without the
skill of acquiring the wealth is uh like
my favorite magic card of all time might
take the gathering um there's card
called burning wish
the flavor text on the card is she
wished for a weapon but for not the
skill to wield it and i always thought
that was so profound because
when you give i feel like money is power
right it's just raw energy that you can
either you know you create hospitals you
can build bombs with it whatever you
want you can do it with money but if you
don't have the skill of learning how to
master and wield money which is in which
is really just learning how to get it to
flow to you if you don't have that skill
that those traits
right if you get it it's like having all
this raw power and i think it ruins
people and so i already knew layla and i
already decided and we just signed our
will this is probably why this is top of
mind for me we signed our wills
a few days ago and when we did that i
realized that we don't have kids and
everything that i've amassed and what's
probably going to become a pretty big
fortune when we die
i'm just donating anyways because i
believe that even if i did have kids
one i wouldn't give it to him and if i
did choose to give it to him here's how
i think how crazy this is from a legacy
standpoint a hundred generations from
now you're diluting your gene pool you
know 100 multiplied like factored right
and so it's like you know cutting by
half cutting by half cutting by half
cutting by half times 100 right
and that's assuming that humans are
still around 100 generations from now
but if they were i'm still not even any
way related to these people and i kind
of ruined them anyways because i'm
giving them wealth that they don't
control and don't understand how it was
generated right and they definitely
don't remember who i was not that that's
that i need that but like just being
real and the other alternative is that
in 100 generations there won't be any
humans right and in that case then the
legacy doesn't matter either and so that
was what was kind of like my ultimate
wraparound with this
of meaning is that nothing inherently
has meaning which als also gives us the
power
to create and destroy meaning as we see
fit but more importantly to rise above
meaning and say
why am i saying that things should or
should not be meaningful and answering
and examining that question has been
very valuable for me as an entrepreneur
because in some ways it's freed up a lot
of my attention because of this
continued
obsession i had or that i have
tendencies towards towards only doing
things that are meaningful when in fact
i feel like my an easier thing that has
been useful for me has been
am i doing things that are in alignment
with my values and those values
to me
are meaningful in and of themselves and
that is all and they don't have to be
that way they shouldn't be that way but
for me doing actions in that way rather
than putting it and casting in the
future
has been a useful mental exercise and so
um i don't know where you're at in your
journey but my name is alex mozy in a
portfolio of of companies that do about
85 million a year i have absolutely
nothing to sell you my goal with
acquisition.com is to
help entrepreneurs uh build their
businesses and you know get financial
freedom the way that we structured
everything is i give away everything um
so the courses the books this book you
can get for 99 cents i have this is the
first of a big series of volumes that
i'm making um of the real stuff that
actually helped us build these companies
um
and then with the hopes that uh that we
can help invest in some of the the
bigger ones that that succeed using
those materials so anyways um lots of
love keep being amazing and uh i will
see you guys next video alright hit
subscribe if you liked it and if you
didn't i still love either way that's
what bye